perú se encuentra profundamente dividido
en una post campaña 99 935 de las actas
procesadas y el país aún no conoce quién
es su presidente seguidores de pedro
castillo piden frente a la sede del
jurado nacional de elecciones que se le
declara ganador por el momento lidera el
balotaje con 49 mil 420 votos de
diferencia con keiko fujimori
[Música]
ya no
por su parte keiko arengó el sábado a
sus seguidores a salir a las calles ante
un supuesto fraude electoral grandes
palabras que la candidata no ha
sustentado con ninguna prueba además
afirma que la izquierda internacional
está detrás del resultado en su contra
[Aplausos]
vamos a permitir
venezuela chavista o demás
la nación
castillo ha pedido a sus seguidores no
caer en las provocaciones surge
humoristas el viernes la organización de
estados américanos afirmó que su misión
de observación descartaba graves
irregularidades en las elecciones pese a
todo él jn todavía no ha declarado
ganador y aún podría tardar varios días
en hacerlo queda un porcentaje menor de
actas por escrutar y todavía debe
revisar las actas que ambas partes pero
en especial keiko fujimori han pedido
anular con una diferencia tan pequeña de
votos su decisión es crucial para el
futuro político de perú